oh hey everybody
you're on sticks out podcast will delay
on season two but we're working through
it
I'm here with Bret star hello hey Bret
Bret where are you from Mountain
magnificent Australia nice and you're on
the east or west side of Australia or
what are you - well the south and right
in the middle right in the middle okay
and what's your problem choice just for
people who don't know okay and does that
count dragon
when you say context F is that like the
same thing or did we say that's
different
dragon stops definitely in there's a
choice as e as is double context of who
you are Bret so like how did you get
into this whole spinning a stick around
being like a hippie flow person
no offense maybe you're not hippie from
Darwin in 2003 and I've been more into
like BMX jumping in this type of thing
and obviously playing with fire was
super cool made you hero so I started
playing around with that I really got
into it I think I moved to Edinburgh in
Scotland in 2005 and Rob father and was
holding uber boy there and I started
with boy and I spun exclusively boy for
about four years and the uber boy made
up was something really special
especially because it was it it was sort
of before a lot of video
without mommy internet and the level of
people that were there was yeah really
incredible I was fairly well technically
advanced in my local scene after
practicing for two years but then yeah
met the likes of burning down the rock
or burn Rashi those yeah quite a few
anyway and then on returning to
Australia I was somewhat poor and when
travelling in my van just spent a lot of
time drilling poi in a forest and it all
sort of spun off from there - wait
you've been sent you've been saying the
word poi a lot and like so when did
contact step enter the picture here it
seems like you know as soon as if these
days you're best known for your context
F prowess not necessarily your ability
[Applause]
Australia was told in Adelaide and it
was actually held on that weekend
just after I got back from Scotland and
there I saw Kyle mcclain playing with
double contact stuff and that was just
out of this world I know that a lot of
the Australian staff spinners that have
been spinning for a while were all
inspired by and of being influenced by
Colin MacLean so I saw that was
incredibly inspired but just went oh my
god that's not something you can learn
that's just Kyle being Kyle must being
2007 late 2007 or 2008 I learnt these
stuff on staff traps
I learnt them from Adam Lobo he learned
them from Jed who figured out something
Kyle was doing
to get them going so actually when in
about 2008 I started double contact
stars and I could do an angel role I
didn't really consider myself a contact
staff spinner and then in 2008 Dragon
focused on that for a while
then I went back to double contact stuff
2011 or so instead of playing with
double contact folding and innovating
some of that stuff then from there I
went to single contact stuff and
probably 2015 or so yeah so it was a
journey especially considering us double
contact before single yeah that's so
weird because my journey is vaguely
parallel because I saw common with cleen
at uber Paris and that was sort of my
beginning contact staff and I learned
from MCP before that who was totally in
love with Cal McLean and my first bit of
doubles contact traps I learned was a
Matt Bray at van Kooten Vancouver Canada
he was the first person that I learned
anything from via Mikey no clue like
kind of like learned most of it so it's
kind of funny to see like the
information passageway through multi
continental channels and kind of a trip
actually it was super Paris I went to I
went to burp eros and that's where I met
Josh Sebastian that whole Romo and that
whole crew and then a couple years later
I was in Canada and random dude Matt
Bray I think was Canada or Portland
juggling festivals somewhere in that
world just was super good at doubles
contact was like crazy you know that's
rising to from so it's kind of funny
Matt and Jed
we're both from Perth so they work
together I think with the doubles
contact and also significantly with
Dragon yeah I was thinking about how
just something recently before the run
some of these questions is how like
Australia is one of those places that is
sort of formative in the contact staff
experience baton spinning is kind of one
of those areas fate somebody's like
historical context for contact staff but
at least in terms of how far as I know
like I was watching some guy named
Benjamin who was from Adelaide as one of
the first contacts that people I ever
saw and yes and this is like way way
long time ago and they were like really
bad downloadable videos and it's just
interesting talking to you now and sort
of seeing how it continues to be that
way is sort of like there's a lineage of
contact staff or doubles contact that is
like come from sort of a nexus of
Australia it's just kind of a trip kind
of a trip to think about how it's one of
the major like lineages of staff even
though it's not maybe as like Christie
is known as like baton spinning or
fascia or things like that but it's
definitely a pretty formative one huh
cause he's seeing call McLean and going
being inspired yeah and then I saw him
do an actor II wore like a monkey tail
and you know he has like a rubber gloves
and of his sticks and it's like the
weirdest thing you've ever seen you're
like what so actually let's start from
the top I got so many cool questions for
you so number one is like so the Chi
roll let's discuss the Chi roll and for
those who don't know like this and what
what is the origin as far as you can
tell of the Chi roll because like it's
one of those things for example like I
know Fei chai probably has something to
do with some sort of feeling there but
like what is your knowledge of where
that she role comes from
so this was back 2011 I think started
playing with Dragon probably mostly 2009
something like this and yeah I'm not I'm
not sure from people doing it so just my
perspective blah blah blah but I found
there was this role which was the static
key role and it seemed really
interesting to me because it's a
two-handed control role that you can do
with both directions links to a lot of
things and it seemed like a sort of
fundamental base for dragon staff and
this circular alternating movement in
bodyõs studying yoga at the time and my
instructor was interested in the flow
stuff that I was doing and he was
getting into shadow yoga
at the time which is a bit more of a
fluid moving style and he said this this
is a really cool movement that you're
doing it's actually very very similar to
this which is focused on rolling energy
around in the upper body from that role
I think the I've got a video that I
don't read it too highly these days but
back in 2011 it was contact compilation
and I put that up and put up around
about that heroes being this possibility
for a base movement for Dragon staff
and at that point I had the static ones
not so there's rolling direction but
then there's also rotation direction
forwards and backwards and Jed Fowler
and that Bray added in the rotational
directions on top of the tiro did you do
you feel like you invented the cheer oh
I'm just curious do you feel like at
least coined the name but maybe do you
feel as if the cheer Oh was going on in
other context efforts or staff arts
before
[Applause]
[Music]
MCP posted a comment on that video going
I knew there would be some use for Kyle
static roles so I'm sure it had been
done but yeah perhaps not seen as such a
potential for a basis of movement so
wait did you did you get learn about the
dragon staff from Goro or deduce leader
and staff before just going back to this
dragon staff thing like 2006 and my idea
was basically let's just pull my wire on
this dude I wasn't thinking so much
about the rolling thing but then it was
yeah I was at a party in 2008 and I
started doing the one-handed fascia
continuous trick and went oh my god this
would look so cool with that we stick
idea I had and I went home and made that
so I hadn't actually seen the dragon
from gora or anyone else and it was
pretty funny actually I I went to 2009
spin fest and I was super excited that I
had this new prop that I'd never seen
before
walked into the juggling Hall with it
and sitting in the corner on the ground
with the dragon stuff I was calling it
the Rollie pollie staff doom doom
because I've made this heavy evil thing
and I just got threaded rod and put it
through one of my contact starts and
angle ground ends off them sharp and I
was always bleeding and gory starves
we're a lot more flimsy than they are
now so I had this well over engineered
engineered system dragon and then yeah
Gauri's was much lighter and then I
spoke to Chris he was like yeah this is
a dragon that's way smarter name I'm
just gonna stop calling it roly-poly
stuff if do me do me do do so yeah then
I I made a dragon for Adam Lobo because
I want her to play mate in exploring the
stuff then Lobo moved to the east coast
and he spread and then did a US trip
yeah yeah so also as well I think before
that he came to fire drums a long time
ago gora as well there's been a couple
dragon all right I got a lot of
questions here here we go just gonna fly
through this what is the origin of your
name Bret star Galactica is it
Battlestar Galactica is this where this
comes from
it was Homer boy and I think there was a
brick or maybe I just saw everyone else
had a funny name
and I had some friends that called me
Bret star because I had fluffy pants and
stars on the bunch so I was like hey
Bret star
and then I think when I joined Facebook
I needed a surname and I was like her
but star Galactica but I haven't seen
Battlestar Galactica but it just seemed
like funny puns okay so you're some
funny ones this is from Kyle Owen
actually yeah he's one of my few patreon
subscribers I have 34 now but he said
flowers yes or no why
so four before you get started you know
for anybody else flowers are those
things you put on your stick and they
flap around they sort of slow down the
rolling capacity what are your thoughts
on flowers in general honor context at
first and also their efficacy and
teaching people different things are
they would you use them all the time
with you not using a sixteen eighteen
[Applause]
and that's because once you've got some
rolling momentum happening a smaller
start won't tend to roll it's much of a
distance for the same rolling momentum
when you've got a larger diameter star I
find it much more beneficial if I'm
playing a twenty two million stars I
really liked her flowers on it
I like the ability of flowers to have a
sort of ramping up and ramping back
effect on the rolling momentum and I
like that control of them but then some
things like you know it's basically
useless for fishtail manipulation and
these type of things and really only for
the longer role so depending on style
and diameter of your staff I think is
where I sit on that one okay all right
so here's a weird one that just
completely changes the thought here why
is there a twister board on your ceiling
in your practice base there's not
anymore actually so it's the Sistine
Chapel marks and sealing twister board
up there it's pretty fun all right so we
got okay so oh man there's some hard
questions here so you went to the United
States once for flow stuff well oh so
some couple things are like what was
some of your big takeaways from your
trip to the States
that's number one so I mean there what
are some techniques some like big things
you took away or like things you were
stuck with you about your trip to States
since it's been three years four years
now yeah what kind of things did you
take away from your trip the trip was an
incredible trip for sure getting to do
that road trip openness the community
and it was it's a bigger anything I've
ever been a part of and spending some
time in that was definitely an amazing
experience seeing the size of the flow
community there and so much happening to
me kind of felt like what I imagined
New Orleans birth of jazz type of thing
you know like this massive pledge
of people all doing creative stuff for
an environment where if you're hanging
out you're just gonna upscale and you
know I live in the countryside in
Australia so it's a very very big
difference another thing that sort of
not spinning related was just the beauty
of the countryside I had started that
trip I was thinking more about the
spinning scene and the people that would
all be like I intentionally did
absolutely no research as to where I was
going like I knew that I was going from
this day to this day with these people
okay well I'll just see what I'm looking
at so as far as I know cornfield
absolutely yeah I'm trying to think of
in terms of influencing style and just
spending some more time the Dave Baron
is he's a phenomenon yeah cool and so so
like what was that okay man there's some
interesting ones here so what was like
the biggest like okay he's got this one
how do you come up with your tricks like
how do you like what like enables you to
feel create like what zone do you get in
to feel creative I mean are you just
like noodling around is it like so like
a plan like you know for example I have
this notebook here with some tricks I'm
working on with like triples and I find
ways to like you know working this but
like how do you what is your process for
like generating new technique or feeling
creative than the technique you have now
like what is that process my process is
really quite informal like I don't have
any
I've got basically no notebooks of stuff
it's more video
the thing with folding is probably a
good example of this so there's that
double contact trick where you chuck a
payroll and neck wrap at the same time
and it does this cool thing where the
sticks are off plane and they push each
other around I think probably just
reminded me cool weird stuff I saw Kyle
doing and I went I want more stuff that
feels like that there must be more stuff
that feels like that so I had an idea of
what I wanted a trick to feel like I
[Music]
sort of alternate between paying
attention to what I'm doing and just
completely not paying attention and so
any now and just continually trying
something again and again and again to
the point where each individual attempt
doesn't really seem to be separate from
any of the other ones and then yeah
eventually from there some coherence
gets distilled like having an idea for a
feeling of something that's it's a loose
enough approach that you can try a lot
of different things chasing there's so
you can still experiment with another
law and find ways that work and ways
that don't and you're not so lot to I
want to make exactly this thing happen
like some of the stuff that I'm working
on now I've been inspired by watching I
wish you
where they do these strikes which is
sort of like this toroidal shape where
the the point is of the sword is sort of
static and isolated and it's this curve
instead of path and that just looks
really cool so I've been playing around
with that and I've been I want to create
that sort of shape and that's the
feeling and I've been doing a lot of
these fishtail things but I've also been
trying to create that with weird Steve's
and angels and so it's yeah all over the
feeling based chasing thing rather than
a plan I've got rules that I do I've
been yeah with non matrix variations and
I've got
oh the this way as many times the other
way that many times and that's that's
more of a foundation to just get really
good control going for like sorry some
hair drying going on in my background
what's your thoughts on like burning out
and doing flow arts like you know what I
mean like it seems like I don't know
about other places but here in the
States
it appears that the lifespan of a flow
artist is probably two to three years
potentially like in like your average
not like the ones that stick around for
a long time but even the ones that stick
around past that I think it
exponentially increases their their drop
off as why do you think that is and what
are your thoughts on like like ways to
not burn out or just stay like
interested or like the two people really
have to at all yeah
yeah sure so well certainly people don't
really have to and I do I do find that
yeah kind of interesting and I think in
I I associate probably more with the
ones that have been around for a long
time like I've done the parts with the
retreat thing with Jeff I caught Dave
Barron's obviously being around in the
scene for years
MCPS a burger some important hangout
Fabio as well there's a few that have
just stuck at this thing like 15 years
and I find I'm generally close to the
ones that I like probably a lot of
shared history there and yourself as
well not sure when you started spinning
well he was at 2003 year somewhere in
that world with toys but to death yes
that's when I learned from that an
Australian from spiritualism
that was my first point teacher like
it's funny like a lot of people I got
from like drag so I learn from Nick
Busey Matt Terry was my boy teacher and
nobody has any even though the dude was
like killing it kind of it like nobody
has any idea who he is but if you ever
are a poi person and want to do some
history research you should not you but
other people should look at Matt Terry
in spiritualism net and a hilarious
video in retrospect spear killer visions
if you can find it man what a funny I
walk past and get in the way of the shot
from Matt Perry as well yeah so
I think it's possibly to do with some
form of probably related to people's
motivations for giving in to doing that
type of thing I'm not sure if I can
eloquently articulate what I see in that
but it's probably a thing that's common
to a lot of things people get excited
about something they think it's going to
be this that in the other that they
punch into it and then the sort of skill
reward curve probably drops off a bit
[Music]
yeah yeah you said something that kind
of got to me a little bit I think one
part of it is feeling like you don't
have any peers anymore
right like this kind of a weird thing to
consider but like not just in age which
is also kind of obvious right you stick
around a scene long enough you're older
a lot of older people that kids are like
between 20 18 and 30 and you're like
dang you're like hitting 38 or something
right like you kind of feel like there's
not a lot of peers in your age but also
peers in terms of ability and experience
right like I don't and I don't want to
like poopoo on people that are getting
started so it's like you know what I'm
saying like somebody shows you something
they come at your dollars enthusiasm and
like finding space to be enthusiastic
about that but I think sometimes burnout
comes from like feeling like yeah it's
not a lot of people that relate to you
in the scene anymore and not just
necessarily inability or a just like
some other kind of thing like spirit and
I think because a lot of people tend to
do this when they're young like okay I'm
down far as many I don't care as much
and then so it's like as that happens
like even for me myself like the group
that I started spinning with like the
original group only like one of seven of
those people still spin at all right you
mean like yes and so yeah so maybe
that's a part of it Hannah yeah get into
during uni years and then jump back out
or something like that
and with the scene being yeah really big
now as well there's probably some stuff
to do with you put some so many years of
practice into something even if it's
three or four and there's that many
people with incredible skill level moves
now that perhaps the recognition and
that validation thing isn't quite as
strong and then yeah that that versus
reward what you get like how quickly you
skill up certainly drops off like I'm
I'm practicing at the moment I've been
practicing anger oh yeah alright two
last questions for you Brad we'll call a
day these are from my keynote number one
is what is your favorite festival snack
and the other one which is and what is
consciousness one second I might have
another question for you
it's gonna look and see hold on okay
good nobody yeah well you don't have to
answer that you don't have anything you
know I mean I don't know you're a doctor
[Music]
integrated information theory of
consciousness but that's it doesn't
really get you too far
so but you're a neuroscience doctor you
can't answer like you don't have a
thought of what Constance is like do you
believe there's more than just like you
know the Machine bits going together is
it like we just like machine bits going
together it's done what's going on here
yeah I mean a low level for sensory
stuff for shorts I think really
mechanical there's some really
interesting things I think there's a
theory about predictive coding where we
basically have a little model of the
world inside of our brain we're trying
to basically predict our own inputs and
work off the errors in our own
predictions so that ability for a system
to create a model of the world with sort
of feedback loop tied to the outside
world so it constitutes some form of
agent that you know has it's not
freewheel and I don't want to say for
you but something that is an aging
environment that has some level of a
model of the external world within it
doesn't even actually need to be a
really good model because all models are
wrong but some are useful
Wow well stay on line for a minute I
just want to thank you for being my
interview today and it seemed thanks for
responding and all the other times I was
planning on it got to all those
questions and yeah thanks for visiting
stay online I'm just gonna turn this
thing off here right
[Music]